at the global price of wheat has shot up
after Moscow indicated it could cancel a
deal to guarantee grain exports from
Ukraine through the Black Sea the
Kremlin says it is not serving Russian
interests
the agreement brokered by the U.N and
turkey last July allows Kiev to export
grain from a number of its black seed
ports around 30 percent is shipped to
lower income countries in Africa and the
Middle East but the biggest overall
share around 20 goes to Turkey
Spain gets 15 percent Egypt gets 10
percent any restrictions on future
exports would likely increase Global
Food insecurity elsewhere in Europe
several countries have banned Imports of
Ukrainian grain farmers in Poland and
Bulgaria say it is driving down their
Farmers prices let's go live now to
journalist Yulia shapovalova for more on
that grain deal she's in Moscow
yesterday the head of the UN said that
he was proposing what he called a way
forward to Russia where are we on these
grain negotiations
absolutely the negotiations are
continuing as we know a U.N Secretary
General Antonio Gutierrez met with
Sergey lavrov on Monday and handed him a
letter for President Vladimir Putin
regarding the the grain deal that letter
was and it suggested further actions
aimed at improving extending and
expanding the grain initiative according
to Gutierrez he considered moscow's
concerns about the supply of Russian
food and fertilizers earlier the G7
agriculture ministers also called for
the full implementation of the grain
deal and we also heard from Turkish
foreign minister mablucha glue on Monday
and according to him Ankara feels it's
pretty realistic to extend the deal if
Russia's demands are met he said it is
important to do this in May otherwise
there will be a food crisis in the world
as it was during the pandemic but
according to evidence spokesperson
Dimitri pescott we just heard from him
several minutes ago the loss of
Ukrainian and Russian grain from the
market will not be the cause of a global
food shortage it said that um the the
um uh basically the the circumstances uh
so far are not in favor of extending the
grain deal but the Russian Federation uh
continues to watch the situation uh
Meanwhile we're also hearing from
Russia's defense Ministry and Iraq used
Ukraine of attempting an attack on its
ships in the Black Sea Monday night
which was a threatening uh prospects for
the deal as well right that's one of
Russia's argument against the deal is
they say that Ukraine has been using it
as cover to attack Russian warships in
the Black Sea look what's this going to
take what's it going to take for Moscow
to extend the deal
right Moscow has repeatedly criticized
the implementation of the agreement
saying that the conditions are not met
and they're met only for the Ukrainian
side so what does Russia actually want
on April the 14th the Russian foreign
Ministry announced five conditions for
extending the grain deal including the
connection of the Russian agricultural
Bank to the Swift payment system the
resumption of supplies to rush of
agricultural Machinery as Fair details
and spare parts and services that fell
under Western sanctions as well as the
lifting of restrictions on insurance for
Russian ships as well as their lifting
of of uh of the ban on their access to
Ports so the grain deal was signed in
July as you mentioned 2022 by
representatives of turkey and the Yuan
on the one hand and representatives of
Russian Ukraine on the other and
separate agreements were assigned with
Moscow and Kiev the first one was for
the export of Ukrainian grain from from
three ports including Adesa Eugene and
chernomorsk and the second one was
actually aimed at assisting Russia in
its exports of agricultural produce and
fertilizers Moscow has repeatedly noted
that the the second part of the deal is
now being implemented and Mr lavrov said
that virtually nothing has been done to
to to remove these restrictions and
overcome all those obstacles and their
Western countries have not yet uh lived
lifted restrictions that prevent the
Russian agricultural exports in March
Russia Russia extended the deal for 60
days and its term expires on the 18th of
May well over in Moscow thank you very
much